angry old guy author and columnist mark
Stein joins us tonight to marvel at how
much rich people hate Trump it's almost
like the same people are always going on
about privilege the more privileged you
are the matter you are about Trump why
is that yeah yeah that's the way to look
at it Robert De Niro lives better than
99.99% of people in the entirety of
human history have ever lived and he
cannot accept that a close election in a
50-50 country didn't go his way this is
deeply bitter you mentioned that you
know I never heard of these American
icon awards and I think it's a faintly
stupid title for award in Australia they
have an award called national treasure
which again doesn't seem like the kind
of thing you get nominated for I mean
these kind of names are in the gift of
the people and the general mood but if
you do actually have something called an
American icon award then the guy has to
be an icon for all Americans including
the 60 whatever million people who voted
for Trump it's it's not just the
Hollywood parties an icon Awards and if
I were out Pacino or anybody else at
risk of getting an award speech prize
presented to me by Robert De Niro I
start carrying the equivalent of an
organ donor card saying in the event
that I get nominated for a prestigious
award I don't want Robert DeNiro coming
and giving the speech because he talks
about Trump for seven minutes and then
says oh and by the way is a statue for
Al Pacino this is this is ridiculous is
this is beyond arrangement he has
actually become more insane than Travis
Bickle in taxi driver well what's
interesting that usually what you know
the revolutionary spirit is aimed upward
you know give the finger to the man in
the last two years you've watched this
parade of again the most privileged
people in our society shouting down at
Trump's voters yeah damn you
working-class Americans you must need to
be quiet how dare you speak has there
ever been a revolution aimed in this
direction down well no I think that's
what in it's interesting
it's a worldwide phenomenon in some ways
the elites rising up against the masses
to add to it no guy but I think that's
actually true I think I saw something of
it
with mrs. Thatcher in in the United
Kingdom where essentially privileged
elite artistic people just regarded her
as vulgar and lower-class in the same
way that they do with Trump but the fact
is they're killing themselves there's a
book out at the moment Oh white by Bret
Easton Ellis as you know the novelist of
American Psycho he voted for Hillary
he's gay he's nobody's idea of a
conservative or right-wing but he was
dating this young millennial guy and the
young millennial guy went full Trump
derangement syndrome and became
impossible to live with and that's the
same situation would you want to wake up
in bed with Robert DeNiro and every
board up pouring on boring all about
boring on about Trump he's actually they
shouldn't have American icon awards they
should have best cranky embittered
grandpa 40 years past his acting best
award because that would he'd be a
shoo-in for that he'd definitely be in
the running so I would argue there are
some other contenders it's a crowded
field and it's not even an age thing as
we saw with Bret Easton Ellis's
insufferable millennial boyfriend it
goes right it spans the ages among the
Hollywood elites the great Mark Steyn
thank you Mark great to see you thanks a
lot Tucker